le thème de ce soir cela le mouvement
perpétuel
la vie c'est le mouvement où tout bouge
même l'humanité n'est pas statique elle
en constante progression et bien le tout
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir où elle se
dirige aujourd'hui à rien qu'ils portent
à sourire en mâchant la tête carrément
donc on peut se demander
je comprends que les gens qui sont
pessimistes ou angoissé aujourd'hui
c'est pas mon cas moi je crois que la
paix se fera alors ça je vous rejoins
tout de suite ça demande une bonne
explication surtout dans le contexte
actuel
quand j'étais môme
j'avais un gros rêve c'était de visiter
tous les pays du monde et tous les
territoires sans exception c'est fait ça
m'a pris plus de 50 ans et j'ai rien
fait d'autre dans la vie j'ai carrément
pris une vie sabbatique
alors ça s'est fait en deux temps
on voit deux colleurs sur la carte du
rouge au noir le premier voyage un
premier voyage qui a duré 18 ont sans
rentrer à la maison de 55 à 60 13 c'est
une dysenterie pas soigné qui m'a fait
rentrer la deuxième partie le rouge
j'étais en france et pendant plus de 30
ans je partais chaque année six sept
huit mois pour finaliser mon rêve
j'ai rien prévu tout s'est enchaîné
malgré moi et je dois quand même avouer
que ma vie ça a été un mouvement
perpétuel
alors je suis parti à l'âge de 17 ans 55
et je n'ose plus parler de ces années-là
aux jeunes parce que ils me prennent
pour l'homme de cro magnon jordi on
n'est pas le téléphone à la maison au
sireme appui on n'aime pas la télé on
n'est pas de guide du routard en fait à
l'époque on parlait pas de voyage on
reconstruisait encore le pays de la
guerre oui un gros problème et beaucoup
de problèmes quand on voyage mais y en
un qui est important c'est le problème
de la communication
aussi j'ai passé les sept premières
années à apprendre des langues en
faisant des petits boulots dans
différents pays d'europe
et je dois dire que l'école hôtelière
que j'ai fait un en avant m'a mis le
pied à l'étrier entre l'espagne et
l'allemagne j'ai passé deux ans au congo
service militaire oblige pour éviter la
guerre d'algérie j'ai pas une vocation
de passoire ensuite j'abrège après bien
un tas d'histoires j'ai intérêt au
canada pour refaire de l'engrais et là
je me suis aperçu d'une chose que je ne
savais pas on paye plus en amérique du
nord qu'en europe
j'ai enfin compris que là je pouvais
économiser pour mon rêve qui était
toujours derrière la tête et avec 3 en
économie à toronto
j'ai pas travailler pendant les six ans
des 18 années dix huit premières années
j'ai pas travailler et là j'ai réalisé
mon rêve en dépensant au compte gouttes
mais j'ai connu me du canada c'est à
dire le dollar par jour alors ce dollar
s'explique pour deux raisons majeures y
en une jeep à payer le transport
j'ai tout fait en stop voilà le croyais
j'ai tout fait au stop
en tout 400 mille kilomètres c'est quand
même la distance de la terre à la lune
j'ai jamais à l'hôtel donc le dollar
servait pour payer la nourriture et les
visages et un tas d'expériences vous
pensez bien
par exemple j'avais été vif chez les
hippies à san francisco au temps de leur
splendeur
chez les bons à bangkok dans les écoles
de yoga en inde
j'ai travaillé dans un kibboutz en
israël j'étais vivre chez les soi-disant
coupeurs de tête à bornéo et j'ai même
passé quelques jours chez le célèbre
docteur albert schweitzer à lambaréné
dans son hôpital du gabon le mans alors
il faut aussi comprendre que je me suis
retrouvé cette fois en prison serait
remarquée dès que je suis rentré j'ai à
la dangereuse
j'ai failli me faire flinguer flinguer
une dizaine de fois pas il faut la
chance d'ailleurs en face de vous la
regardez bien vous avez un miraculé en
plus ça oui j'ai été déporté plusieurs
fois mais j'adore c'est gratos
vous êtes en train de vous demander mais
pourquoi faire tout ça mais moi aussi je
me suis posé la question en fait je
dirais pour apprendre mais la vraie de
vraie raison est apparue au bout d'une
quinzaine d'années moi je suis né avant
la guerre la deuxième je voyais et mes
premiers souvenirs la vie c'est la
guerre mais pas la guerre à la télé on
n'a pas la télé à l'époque on avait des
faut dire qu'il souvenirs de
l'enfance pour chacun de nous c'est très
important c'est comme un sac à dos
l'intérieur contre un mal toute sa vie
pour vous dire pardon quand j'étais
enfant moi je rêvais je faisais un
cauchemar récurrent
je me voyais devant un peloton de la
gestapo en train de me fusiller ça
commençait fort et aujourd'hui soixante
dix ans après quand j'entends la larme
qui s'essaye à la mairie de mon bled la
boue si à chaque fois le savez j'ai même
aujourd'hui j'ai encore un pincement au
coeur
mon premier réflexe est de courir à la
cave parce que pour moi se brûla annonce
les bombardements quand on voit là la
carte du voyage la regarder ça exact
dans tous les sens c'est pas un tour du
monde ça c'est pas un cercle gmi appeler
ça un tour des hommes et moi ce que j'ai
voulu faire c'est rencontrer les hommes
du monde entier pour savoir une question
essentielle suite à mon enfance dans la
guerre est ce qu'un jour les ombres est
capable d'établir la paix alors j'avoue
que d'autres passé sanglant ne porte
guère à y croire en plus on n'a jamais
eu la paix ne peut pas l'imaginer on
peut pas imaginer ce qu'on connaît pas
pourtant ce qu'ils me disent que la paix
n'est pas possible les regarde pas bien
l'histoire
regardez l'europe elle l'a fait mais
c'est un miracle quand on regarde le
passé de ce continent dont deux guerres
mondiales
vous êtes déjà trimballer dans la
campagne devrait déjà vu des rondes et
chenilles sur les ronces bas berck
sépara goûtant comment imaginer le
papillon qui est dedans si on ne savait
pas gascon mais jusqu'à date je pense
dans l'histoire d'humanité c'est la
période chenilles et j'avoue qui est
très très difficile d'imaginer le bon
papillon de l'appel à nan mais je dis
que si à chenilles il ya papillon alors
il ya une chose qui est nouvelle dans
l'histoire des hommes et de l'humanité
ça vient de sortir c'est nouveau il ya
plus de dix ans
ce pour la première fois de son
existence la grande famille humaine est
relié réuni interdépendantes bref on est
tous dans le même bateau
il va falloir en tenir compte alors
comment bâtir la paix c'est pas
important de savoir qu'elle va se faire
ce qui est important c'est de savoir
comment on va faire alors première chose
ya trois petits pas à faire à mon avis
d'abord comprendre que la terre n'est
qu'un seul pays
c'est le titre de mon premier livre la
terre n'est qu'un seul pays s'est fait
techniquement mais malheureusement c'est
pas fait dans les esprits deuxièmement
il faut admettre qu'il ya une seule
espèce humaine
oui ces scientifiques on est tous frères
on a tous un coeur et des sentiments et
aussi il faut comprendre qu'il n'ya pas
trente-six religion ça c'est peut-être
le plus important à comprendre qu'est ce
que c'est que la religion fait d'après
-7 ce n'est qu'un simple code de
conduite qui a été expliqué aux hommes
au cours de l'histoire par de grands
éducateurs universel les fondateurs de
civilisation alors c'est les gens comme
moïse le crissement mais bouddha krishna
sort as tes autres pourquoi et bien tout
simplement parce que c'est indispensable
ce code de conduite est indispensable à
l'épanouissement de l'individu au vivre
ensemble et à la préparation de la vie
au delà pour ceux qui veulent bien y
croire
ce qu'il faut comprendre en fait ces cas
qu'un seul yves d'instruction pour tout
le monde depuis le début il y en a qu'un
seul voilà mais ce livre unique comme
tous les livres comme les miens aussi
ont beaucoup de chapitres donc enfin à
mesure que l'humanité progrès ce nouveau
chapitre est additionné pour les
nouveaux besoins et la nouvelle
compréhension
le jour on va comprendre ça que c'est le
même livre pour tout le monde eh bien je
pense que les conflits de religion
disparaître maintenant savoir comment
bâtir la paix alors il ya une logique
pour bâtir la paix mais il faudra un
homme de paix voit-il pas les maisons
noël avec des vieilles briques
donc il faudra donc commencer par soi
même
la recette a déjà été donné peut-être
vous faire sourire mais j'en vois pas
d'autres c'est aimez vous les uns les
autres
il s'agit de l'appliquer
mais également il va falloir s'occuper
de l'humanité au niveau collectif
parce qu'il n'y a aucun système
aujourd'hui qui répondent aux besoins du
jour donc ça a été c'est ça la grande
découverte de mon voyage
voilà pourquoi j'ai fait tout ça c'est
parce qu'en fait il y a eu un plan
administratif mondiale pratiques pour
gérer la terre comme une seule entité
politique qui a été révélé au 19e siècle
on perce est étonnamment je peux pas
jouer à maquereau mais il est en marche
ça fonctionne la paix a bel et bien
démarré
c'est ça que j'ai vu mais moi j'ai rien
à prouver je suis pas reporter je suis
rien du tout mais je l' ai vu j'en
témoigne alors un tout petit mot sur ce
plan il faudra le pouvoir ne doit plus
être investis dans un seul bonhomme
comme on l'a fait jusqu'à date pour
éviter les abus et les dégâts que ça
donnait dans le passé le plan propose de
mettre le pouvoir entre les mains d'une
collégialité de neuf membres pour
l'instant élu démocratiquement chaque
année qui n'ont le pouvoir que
lorsqu'ils sont réunis et quand ils
voient la maison soit aucun n'a le
pouvoir parce qu'il faut qu'ils soient
ensemble oui l'astuce et pour que ça
marche il ya deux autres choses à
appliquer qui n'ont jamais été utilisés
dans l'histoire pratiquement il y en a
un c'est tout le monde éligibles et
l'autre ces propagandes électorales
interdite alors sa part utopique ce que
j'ai là mais moi je dis que je l' ai vu
c'est en match je dirais que ceux qui
étudient ce plan là oui bah ils disent
tous ça c'est l'idéal
eh bien on verra si la mouvance
mouvement de l'histoire la dot en tout
cas à chacun de juger
pour terminer et pour vous remercier de
votre aimable attention
j'aurais aussi tu es une des maximes
deux fondateurs de ce plan persan du 19e
siècle il dit il a écrit la gloire
aujourd'hui n'est pas pour celui qui
aime son pays
il est pour celui qui aime le monde
entier merci
violent